ils partent pour une heure de course
une boucle d'un kilomètre contre la faim
pour les 6e et 5e du collège alexandre
dumas de maurepas ils ont une heure de
sensibilisation par des bénévoles de
l'action de l'association action contre
la faim
donc tous les élèves ont eu une heure de
sensibilisation sur ce que c'était que
l'action contre la faim la notion d'eau
potable dans ces pays des familles
souvent voie développement défavorisés
paieront 5 tours 8 ou plus certains
cours près de dix kilomètres des
distances échanger contre des dons de
sponsors qu'ils ont eux mêmes trouver
cette année les fonds partiront en
ethiopie avait des gens de notre âge qui
lui vit pas comme nous et qui met pas à
voir même si je pouvais pas bénéficié de
la même rupture de boissons comme on en
mange on en voit tous les jours et donc
moi ça me tenait à coeur dû courir pour
eux quand on pense que c'est pour la
bonne cause
pâton à main c'est pas assez moins que
d'habitude c'est moins douloureux
le collège alexandre dumas participent à
cette course nationale depuis plus de
dix ans l'an passé les élèves avaient
récolté près de 5000 euros